>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Helena E. Wright: Well,
good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the director of the Center
for the Book at the library,
which is the reading and
literacy promotion arm.
We're very pleased to have you
here for one of our noontime talks.
The Center for the Book itself
was created long time ago
by Daniel Boorstin when he
was Librarian of Congress.
And the general idea was
to reach out to the public
to promote books and reading.
We were actually created in 1977
when people really weren't
talking much about literacy.
But the big fear was television
and the technology of television,
and we very quickly moved into the
business of using new technologies
to promote books and reading
with our first project,
a something called "read more about
it" that people my age will remember
on CBS television when for
a year, more than a year,
the star of the program
came out and said,
"if you enjoyed the program
the library suggests,
the Library of Congress
suggests these books."
"Go to your local library or
bookstore, they'll be happy
to help you read more about it."
Implied message, don't go to the
Library of Congress [laughter].
But the positive message, we're
promoting bookstores and libraries.
We also are involved with
some national events went
through the Center for the book,
the major one being the
National Book Festival,
which celebrated its
15th year, this year.
We are also, the administer, the new
Library of Congress literacy awards.
And finally, our other claim
to national fame is a network
of state centers for the book that
promote books, reading, literacy,
and libraries in all
of their states.
This Books and Beyond series
started in, could it be 1996?
Yes, no, 2006.
Gosh, the decade's just
roll by [laughter].
Whatever it takes to get up to the
number of more than 350 of them.
They are filmed, they're
videotaped here for showing later
on the Library of Congress website,
so I ask you to please turn
off all things electronic.
The schedule will be,
well, first of all,
I want to say that the other Helena,
Helena Zinkham is not
able to join us today.
She was to introduce Helena
Wright, but she is not here.
I'm going to actually use the
introduction that Helena penned
for me a few minutes ago about her
background, but I want to come back
to the purpose of Books and Beyond.
This is the book that will be
discussed and presented today.
And the purpose of Books and Beyond
really is to show off new books
that are based on extensive
research, either in the Library
of Congress or in other
institutions.
And also, to highlight writers
that are of special interest
to the Library of Congress, often
through involvement in projects
or through collections that
they've donated to the library.
So we're proud of the connection
between the Library of Congress
and its collections and
the production of books.
And I think it's good for us
to, every once in a while,
to have that sharp edge
to show what the product
of all of this research is.
And today's speaker has done a
prodigious amount of research
on this wonderful book, and Helena
is using the short title, I see,
for, on her screen, the Marsh
Collection, the Smithsonian,
and the Library of Congress.
The bibliographer in me wants
to read the entire title
so you know what this
is really about.
It's "The First Smithsonian
Collection: The European Engravings
of George Perkins Marsh
and the Role of Prints
in the US National Museum."
Wide range, and really
covers a number of topics.
And in addition to being a head
of the center for the book,
I'm very interested in
Library of Congress history.
So there's a great deal of LC
history which Helena will mention,
as in passing at least, as
we move through her talk.
It really reflects a lot of
Washington DC history too,
so I was really delighted to have
this and I took some careful notes
about people like George
Perkins Marsh,
who was on the Library
Committee in the 19th century
to advise the Librarian of Congress,
and really helped the library a
good deal through the 19th century.
But he was a man of many talents,
you'll learn about him in the talk.
But interestingly enough, he was
one of those members of Congress
in mid-19th century that
thought that maybe the Library
of Congress couldn't handle being
a national library and favored it
at the Smithsonian
Institution shortly
after the Smithsonian
was, was created.
That's only a small part
of the story however.
That obviously didn't happen,
but Mr. Marsh is really quite a,
a scholar for being
a member of Congress,
and we'll learn more about him.
Helena herself has served as
a curator of, as the curator
of graphic arts at the
Smithsonian's Museum
of American History since 1983.
She's organized many exhibitions.
I'm not going to talk about
her several publications.
One of the exhibitions was on
Audubon and the Smithsonian
for the Smithsonian libraries.
She also has done research and work
on Kallitype printing, papermaking,
and the history of print collecting,
which led to the research
that you're about to learn about,
and to the research about all
of the writing of this
wonderful book.
It's my pleasure to
present Helena Wright.
Helena.
[ Applause ]
>> Helena E. Wright: Thank you John.
I appreciate having the
opportunity to speak here today,
and I also appreciate John's
assistance during my research.
He introduced me to Carl
Ostrowski's excellent history
of the antebellum Library of
Congress, and he also introduced me
to Cheryl Fox in the
manuscript division, excuse me,
who was a helpful guide
to resources there.
And Helena Zinkham, Katherine Blood,
and Barbara Natanson in the prints
and photographs division
provided wonderful
and generous collegial
support and encouragement
as I spent many sessions there
looking for the Marsh prints
that remain at the library.
And perhaps I should alert Mark
Dimunation and Eric Frazier
that Marsh's books
represent the next frontier
in this continuing project.
To begin, I will present
an overview of my book,
and John has already
read you the full title
so I don't need to do that, I guess.
It brings together Marsh's
passion as a collector,
his role in the formation
of the Smithsonian
and the somewhat checkered
history of the collection.
Then I will discuss the specific
points where Marsh, the Smithsonian,
and the Library of Congress
intersected over the years.
You will see examples of his
prints throughout my talk.
Marsh, a Vermont congressman and
a member of the Smithsonian Board
of Regents, sold his
collection of European engravings
to the Smithsonian in 1849, only
three years after its founding.
The Smithsonian demonstrated
remarkable prescience
in acquiring the collection, but
displayed a good deal of uncertainty
about what to do with it.
To be fair, not only was
it the first collection
of any kind acquired
by the new institution,
six years before the
castle was completed,
it was also the first public
print collection in the nation
and there were no models to
reference what it should be
or how it would function.
So by 1874, most of the prints had
been sent to the Library of Congress
and to the Corcoran Gallery of Art.
Efforts to reclaim them,
however, began early in the 1880s.
In telling this story, I
wanted to dispel the myth
that the collection had
been destroyed in the fire,
the 1865 fire that gutted
portions of the castle.
And I wanted to recover Marsh's
reputation as a print connoisseur
in the antebellum period,
when that avocation was rare.
I also wanted to provide some
context for the wider reception
of prints that developed
in the United States
during the 19th century.
Marsh acquired important engravings
and illustrated volumes at a time
when such collections were
uncommon, and their presence
in two national institutions led me
to investigate their acquisition,
dispersal, and continuing influence.
The narrative builds in
somewhat spiral fashion,
from a basic introduction to
the man and the institutions,
through a detailed
account of the collection
and the National Museum
in the 19th century.
For the most part, I present this
history in chronological order,
based on documents
and correspondence,
in the words of the
participants wherever possible.
Three appendices reproduce
the most critical documents,
Marsh's 1849 sales agreement,
and here are two examples
of different versions that I
found, but not the original
which we presume was in
fact lost in the fire.
The 1850 Smithsonian annual report,
which describes the collection
in detail and served as the
basis for many later accounts.
And in 1874 a list of the prints
that were sent to the Corcoran,
which were returned in 1896.
Chapter One provides a brief
history of the Smithsonian,
including James Smithson's
unexpected and undefined bequest
that founded the institution.
Marsha's active role in
founding in its formation,
through his appointment to the
congressional committee charged
with deciding the best use
for the Smithson bequest,
and a preliminary description
of the collection
and the somewhat secretive
circumstances surrounding
the purchase.
Chapter Two presents a biography
of Marsh, offering an account
of his many interests
and accomplishments.
Today he's best known as the
guiding spirit, the sort of guru
of the environmental movement,
for his influential book "Man
and Nature" which was
first published in 1864.
But my study emphasizes his
earlier artistic interests
and his long-term connection
to the Smithsonian.
Chapter Three places Marsh in
the context of the art market
of the 1840s and explores
the cultural background
at the time the Smithsonian
acquired the collection.
It introduces other antebellum
collectors, three men in particular,
who had connections to Marsh
and to each other, Ithiel Town,
Robert Gilmore Junior,
and Francis Calley Gray.
Marsh's dealers and his specific
acquisitions are discussed
to provide a view of the book trade
and to demonstrate his
developing connoisseurship.
Rather remarkably for the time, he
acquired the collection entirely
in the United States before his
diplomatic assignments took him
abroad, unlike these
three gentlemen,
who began to form their collections
when traveling in Europe.
Chapter Four relates the history of
the collection at the Smithsonian
up to the crisis of the 1865 fire
and its subsequent dispersal.
It provides an overview of
the first quarter century
of the Smithsonian's activities
with a new focus on the library,
the role of the library, and
the non-scientific collections.
Contrary to the generally accepted
image of the early Smithsonian
as exclusively scientific,
Marsh's prints were in place more
than a year before
Spencer Baird and his boxes
of natural history
specimens arrived,
and nearly a decade
before exhibition cases
of those objects filled the
lower main hall of the castle.
Other histories of the
Smithsonian have concentrated
on the scientific programs,
which dominated the institution
for most of the 19th century.
To better understand the
Smithsonian's evolving organization
and changing priorities,
I traced what happened
to the Marsh collection over time.
Ultimately surrounded by thousands
of birds, fishes, mammals,
and minerals, the collection
may seem small by comparison,
but every mention of it has allowed
me to construct a fuller picture
of the Smithsonian's history
and the collection's role
within the institution.
Chapter Five treats the growth of
the art market after the Civil War,
with particular emphasis on
the reception and exhibition
of prints nationwide, including
the etching revival and the role
of new photo-mechanical
reproduction processes.
It introduces significant
collectors like James Cleghorn,
whose activities impacted
the Smithsonian,
and it addresses the
growing body of literature
that informed new audiences
about prints.
These developments influenced
the Smithsonian's efforts
to expand the National Museum
after 1880 with the construction
of what's now the Arts
and Industries building.
Chapter Six recounts the formation
of the Division of Graphic Arts
at the Smithsonian in 1886, and
related developments at the Library
of Congress in the late 1890s.
It describes the Smithsonian
deposit that includes portions
of the Marsh collection along
with 40,000 books sent
to LC after the fire.
LC's use of the collection and
its subsequent print acquisitions
and exhibitions are discussed
in the context of the role
and reception of prints
in the period.
It was at this time that the
Smithsonian began its efforts
to reclaim the Marsh
collection from the library,
and from the Corcoran Gallery
of Art, with only mixed success.
I will say everything came
back from the Corcoran,
but a considerable number of prints
and books remain here
at the library.
Chapter Seven includes an account
of Secretary Langley's construction
of the art room in the castle,
where many of the prints
and books resided, and it covers
the Smithsonian's acquisition
of art collections in the 20th
century, primarily painting
and sculpture, and its designation
as the first National
Gallery of Art.
Prints remained outside the scope of
that department for the most part,
and in the later history
of the Marsh collection,
I address that paradox.
Chapter Seven also treats
the eventual confusion
about the collection's origins, its
rumored destruction in the fire,
and its current location.
Chapter Eight concludes
the book with a discussion
of the Smithsonian's role in the
formation of national identity
through the lens of visual
culture, informed by museum studies
and broader historical references.
I summarize the issues surrounding
the reception of print collections
as they moved from private ownership
into museums and libraries,
reflecting on the legacy of Marsh's
experience as part of this process.
As many of you know, the Library
of Congress initially was intended
solely for the use of Congress.
Only later, and somewhat
grudgingly, were privileges added
for Cabinet officers and
members of the Judiciary branch.
Due to the limited scope of the
Congressional Library in the 1840s,
when it occupied a single
room in the capital,
several legislators wanted
to use the Smithson bequest
to develop a more expansive
national library.
They looked to the
nascent Smithsonian
as a possible alternative.
Both the House and Senate had
separate library committees
that together functioned as the
Joint Committee on the Library
to provide oversight on the
purchase of books and the regulation
of the Congressional Library.
During his first term in
Congress, Marsh was appointed
to the House Library Committee.
He voted to increase the library's
budget, and he participated actively
in the congressional debates
over the Smithson bequest.
In 1845, Marsh was appointed to
the seven-member select committee
of the Congress charged with
ending the years of wrangling
and recommending a course of
action to determine how best
to implement the Smithson bequest.
In this capacity, he was
an important advocate
for developing the
intellectual direction
of the Smithsonian
during the debates
that framed the new institution.
In the House, Marsh worked closely
with his fellow New England Whig,
John Quincy Adams, to present
the case for the Smithsonian
to become the National Library.
They advocated on behalf
of the library plan,
and though in the minority,
they succeeded
in keeping a library as
part of the proposal.
In April 1846, Marsh developed,
delivered an eloquent speech before
the House detailing the arguments
for a National Library.
In his remarks, he stressed
that despite James
Smithson's personal involvement
in the sciences, the benefactor
made no special provision
for his eponymous institution
to promote science.
Marsh did not oppose the
scientific orientation
of other interests bearing on
the formation of the Smithsonian,
but he felt that a library would do
more to affirm Smithson's language
in the bequest, the
now famous increase
and diffusion of knowledge clause.
Among several means to accomplish
this end, he felt the simplest
and most efficient would be
the provision for a library,
a museum, and a gallery of art.
The tenor of his speech conveys
the sense of intellectual values
that Marsh, who was, in my
opinion, the consummate humanist,
had found in studying
his own books and prints.
As signed into law by President
James K. Polk on August 10th 1846,
the Smithsonian's enabling
legislation provided
for the establishment of a Board of
Regents to govern the institution,
a building with rooms suitable
for the reception and arrangement
of objects of natural history, a
chemical laboratory, a library,
a gallery of art, and lecture rooms.
It also provided for the transfer
to the institution of all objects
of art and foreign and curious
research, natural history plants,
geological and mineralogical
specimens, namely the gatherings
of the U.S. exploring
expedition and other collections
that were then housed
at the patent office.
And, the deposit in the Smithsonian
of one copy of all publications,
books, prints, maps and charts,
copyrighted under act of Congress.
Yes, for several years, the LC
and the SI shared the
fruits of copyright deposit.
The new institution was
to be supported entirely
with private funds generated
by Smithson's bequest.
Its government appropriation
and the official establishment
of the U.S. National Museum
would come a decade later.
The Smithsonian's Board of Regents
included six members of Congress,
several of whom were active
in LC oversight as well.
Maryland Senator James Alfred Pierce
chaired the Executive Committee
of the Regents, and in that
capacity, he approved the purchase
of Marsh's collection
for the Smithsonian.
He also chaired the Joint
Congressional Committee
on the Library, and as Ostrowski
argues in a fine article
about Pierce, his domineering
leadership limited the LC's
acquisitions, scope, and access
in the years before the Civil War.
Joseph Henry, a distinguished
scientist
and the first Smithsonian secretary,
wanted to concentrate the
institution's financial resources
on scientific research
and publication.
And yet, rather surprisingly,
Henry not only approved,
but personally advanced funds for
the acquisition of Marsh's prints.
No doubt he considered the purchase
to be politically expedient.
Even so, it seems odd that the SI's
first major acquisition was some
1300 European engravings
and 300 art books.
Hailed as translations of the best
creations of genius in painting
and sculpture, the collection
was viewed as a comprehensive way
for the new institution to cover
every department of the fine arts
and satisfy the congressional
mandate for a gallery.
But the purchase occurred before
the Smithsonian had completed its
building, or found its direction,
and the organization didn't know
quite what to do with this treasure.
Marsh had to sell portions
of his library
to cover serious financial losses.
In May 1849, he formally offered
to sell the Smithsonian his prints
and books for $3000 as he
prepared to take up his new post
as U.S. minister to Turkey.
Acquisition of the Marsh
collection was decidedly premature.
The new institution was still
under construction in every sense.
Funds were tight with most
expenditures going toward completing
the castle, and the Marsh
purchase was kept very quiet
until a publication of
the 1850 annual report.
Neither Henry nor the
librarian, Charles Coffin Jewett,
mentioned Marsh by name, as he had
requested strict anonymity in regard
to the purchase, probably to
keep his creditors at bay.
Jewett considered a print collection
the best opportunity to the,
available to the institution
because he was not very optimistic
about the prospect
for acquiring painting
and sculpture of a similar caliber.
The purchase represented
a remarkable,
if somewhat a rudimentary,
understanding within the Smithsonian
of the potential role for
public art collection.
As Jewett observed, engraving
seems to be the only branch
of the fine arts which we can,
for the present, cultivate.
One good picture or
statue would cost more
than a large collection of prints.
It can hardly be doubted that in
no way could this institution do
so much for every department
of the fine arts
as by procuring a collection
of engravings, so full
and so well-chosen, as that
which now adorns its library.
He went on to describe the
collection as containing some
of the best works of nearly
every engraver of much celebrity,
one portfolio of Dürer, another
of the etchings of Rembrandt,
superb portraits by [inaudible],
Villa, [inaudible] and others,
a portfolio of prints from the
old Italian masters and another
from the old German masters.
Given the uncertainty of
the Smithsonian's mission
in the early years, it's open
to question whether the collection
was purchased for its aesthetic
and educational value,
its political expediency,
or to help Regent Marsh during
his financial difficulty.
Henry suggested the prints would
form part of the Gallery of Art,
but they never were displayed
there and remained in the library.
Reviewing the stages of the
castle's completion and occupation,
together with a few archival sources
that mention the collection's
movements,
help to clarify its historical role.
We know it was received during
the spring and summer of 1849.
At that point, only the east wing
and range, shown here in purple,
were finished and occupied.
The books and prints were put in
order in a small room by themselves,
near Jewett's office on the
second floor of the east range.
Then early in 1850, Jewett began to
move them across to larger spaces
in the newly completed west
wing and range, circled in red,
designated for the library.
The move was complicated
by a partial collapse
of the interior flooring of
the unfinished main hall,
the large portion, central
portion of this plan.
As a result of this accident
and subsequent reconstruction,
the main hall was essentially
empty until 1855
when the local mechanics fair
occupied the space temporarily.
Legislation in 1857 established
a government appropriation
for the National Museum.
In the summer of 1858, Curator
Spencer Baird began to bring
over the collections
from the patent office,
an effort that continued
until, through 1862.
So the museum function of the
Smithsonian began to take shape,
filling the castle's main hall
with scientific specimens.
The Marsh collection
was not displayed there.
It remained, as it had
during the previous decade,
in the library in the west wing.
Marsh's portfolios of prints and
art volumes rested in bookcases
in the gothic style library.
Until completion of
the upper main hall,
the apps at the North End served
as a gallery for the paintings
of Indian life loaned by
the artist John Mix Stanley.
This illustration published
in 1853 is one
of the earliest interior views, and
one of the few contemporary sources,
that indicate visually how the
Smithsonian spaces were used
by the public.
The genteel figures conveys the
tenor of Jewett's, Jewett's comment
about those who enjoyed
Marsh's collection.
It had attracted much interest,
not from undiscriminating idlers,
but from men of taste and
particularly from artists.
Henry recognized the institution's
investment in the prints
and his references to the
collection during the 1850s
and 60s suggested it
served as a marker
of the cultural authority he
hoped the works would bring
to the institution.
Invariably, in annual
reports, he referred to it
as "this valuable collection
of engravings."
While no catalog was ever issued,
some of the prints were framed
and hung in different
parts of the building.
The only Marsh print specifically
identified as being exhibited
in this way was Rembrandt's
etching, Christ healing the sick,
which an 1861 guidebook located in
the west range near the library.
Selling his collection
to the Smithsonian reinforced the
library plan promoted by Marsh
and his allies for the
direction of the institution.
Such a prestigious gathering
of European cultural sources
formed an important nucleus
for the Smithsonian library
and should have argued
for its continued support, although
the situation changed dramatically
in less than a decade.
Henry dismissed the
librarian Jewett in 1854,
and then after the 1865 fire,
he dispersed the library,
sending it with most
of the Marsh collection
to the Library of Congress.
Many people have assumed
the collection was destroyed
at that time, but the west wing
of the castle was undamaged.
What did burn was the Gallery
of Art that had moved in 1854
to the second floor
of the main hall,
which as you can see is
roofless in this photo.
That resulted in the loss of the
paintings of Native Americans
by Stanley and Charles Bird
King that Henry had regarded
as an ethnological
gallery of much interest.
While not damaged by the fire,
the Marsh collection did
effectively disappear
into the somewhat amorphous
Smithsonian deposit at LC.
Several dozen engravings that
remained behind were sent
to the new Corcoran Gallery of Art
where Henry served on the board
when that opened in 1874.
The institutional memory
of the Marsh collection did not
fade completely with its dispersal.
Following Henry's death in 1878,
Marsh's protégé, Spencer Baird,
became secretary, and within a
few years he initiated efforts
to retrieve the collection.
When the new U.S. National Museum
building opened next to the castle
in 1881, the graphic
arts became part
of Baird's classification scheme
for the arts and industries,
taking as its scope the development
of engraving, engraving processes
over time, which had
been Marsh's focus
for his collection
forty years before.
Graphic arts exhibits were
developed during the 1880s,
and Sylvester Koehler was
hired as curator in 1886.
Baird invoked the Marsh collection
early in his correspondence
with Koehler, telling him
that they expected to draw
on Marsh's collection to illustrate
the early history of engraving.
In Baird's mind, the
prints could be recalled,
but unfortunately not every
item could be located.
The engraving sent to the
Corcoran had been listed.
They were identified
and returned in 1896.
But retrieving the larger portion
of the collection from the Library
of Congress resulted
in only mixed success.
Some items were returned in 1888 for
the expanding graphic arts exhibits
in the National Museum,
but the reclamation efforts were
severely hampered by the deaths
of those men who were most involved.
Baird died in 1887, Assistant
Secretary George Brown Goode died
in 1896, and Koehler died in 1900.
Even more critical for the
Marsh collection and the role
of graphic art within the
SI, no curator was appointed
to follow Koehler for twenty years.
Samuel Pierpont Langley became
secretary on Baird's death
and he continued the attempts
to recover the prints.
Competition for old
master-prints was keen at the time,
with the formation of art museums
in several American cities,
an active group of
wealthy collectors,
and rising prices in the art market.
Langley wanted to report to the
regents on the present condition,
artistic and pecuniary value
of the Marsh collection.
So in 1893, he inquired at LC about
the accessibility of the prints
and facilities for
their examination.
But the library also
realized their value
and had become rather
attached to them [laughter].
Moreover, they were busy
constructing a new building
and they kept putting the
Smithsonian off with the excuse
that they would look
for the collection
when they moved things
out of the Capital.
In the late 1890s, Langley,
as I said, created an art room
in the castle where most of
the returned items were kept,
those that were not on exhibition.
In an ironic coincidence,
Marsh's collection returned
to the second floor of the
East Range near the spot
where it had first entered the
Smithsonian fifty years before.
The 1865 fire at the Smithsonian
followed a serious fire here,
not here in this building, but
here at the library in 1851,
and the construction in
1852 of fireproof rooms
in the library's quarters
at the Capital.
This created a circumstance which
offered Joseph Henry the opportunity
to find a new home for the
Smithsonian's books and prints.
With Ainsworth Rand Spofford's
appointment as Librarian of Congress
in 1864, a more expansive and
truly national role became possible
for the library.
Eventually it developed
into the kind of institution
that the proponents of the
library plan, including Marsh
and John Quincy Adams, had
argued for the Smithsonian to be.
Henry and Spofford worked together
to secure a passage of a law signed
on 5th of April, 1866, which
defined the arrangement
between the two institutions.
Like all relationships, this
one required some attention,
but its official basis
in law encouraged the
resolution of most problems.
The Smithsonian did not surrender
ownership of its library,
which became known officially
as the Smithsonian deposit.
There were benefits
to both institutions
in that the Smithsonian gained space
and saved resources formally
expended on managing a library.
Henry had ended the Smithsonian's
role as a copyright depository
in 1858, they were being
absolutely inundated with material
that was way out of
scope for the SI.
And the library received
nearly 40,000 volumes
that represented an
invaluable scientific department
without material cost.
The largest portion of the deposit
resulted from the exchange program
of the transactions of learned
societies and other scientific
and technical journals received from
many organizations around the world.
These works continued to be received
at the Smithsonian
on a regular basis.
So staff members at both
institutions were assigned
to handle the flow of additions
to the deposit at the library.
Through the success of the exchange
program and the sole proprietorship,
as it were, of copyright deposit,
the Library of Congress collections
grew exponentially during
Spofford's tenure.
Their growth soon prompted a
need for physical expansion
and improved intellectual
control, two issues that often came
up in the library's annual reports.
Overcrowding became a serious
problem in the Capital, and by 1886,
plans for a separate
building had been approved.
At the time of the first Smithsonian
inquiries about the Marsh prints,
Spofford had to deal with
more pressing concerns related
to the building and the collections.
Without documentation regarding
the contents of the deposit,
he had some excuse for delay.
But as will be shown, there
was also an ulterior motive
in his muted response.
The Smithsonian's attempts
to restore the Marsh collection were
driven by the exhibition program
at the new National Museum,
and an ambitious agenda
of participating in
national expositions.
To complete the historical series
for the permanent Washington
installation,
and a large temporary exhibit
held in Cincinnati in 1888,
Koehler needed to acquire
old master-prints
and specific reproductive
engravings.
He worked with Assistant Secretary
Goode to investigate the status
and location of the Marsh collection
in the hope of including items
from it in his planned exhibitions.
The Smithsonian did
retrieve some items
from the library early in 1888.
These included Marsh's German
album, the two large folio volumes
of Houghton Gallery, and
three Dürer woodcuts.
Koehler entered the three Dürer
prints and six other items removed
from these volumes into his
print accession book in 1889.
As he stated that year in his annual
report, "I would further suggest
that what is left of the Marsh
collection, bought in 1849,
be definitely turned over to
the section of graphic arts."
Unfortunately, the largest and most
desirable parts of this collection,
including all the fine
Dürer and Rembrandts,
etc. which the original
inventory enumerates,
have unaccountably disappeared.
But there still remain several
volumes of single prints
and presumably the various
gallery works belonging to it,
which if added to the present
collections of the section,
would considerately
increase their interest.
Koehler also argued for the return
of books from Marsh's library.
He believed they offered a nucleus
of great value for the section
of graphic arts, which
needed technical
and historical works of reference.
He probably retrieved Marsh's copy
of [inaudible] dictionary of artists
and Longhi's treatise on
engraving at this time.
Other volumes returned
in 1888 included a few French
works on art and design.
It's not clear exactly
how many books
or portfolios actually
were returned,
a point which arose
in later discussions.
Copies of the original sales
agreement identified the books
by title, but did not itemize
the prints within the portfolios.
The collection was not accessioned
or registered when it first arrived
at the Smithsonian nor when
it was sent to the library.
But there was some system that
employed red and blue checkmarks,
perhaps related to a lost list.
It seems that by the late
1880s, the portfolios
that Marsh had designated,
containing works by Dürer
and Rembrandt, either could not
be located or had been broken up.
It's possible they
had been picked over,
or some of their contents lost,
either during their early years
in the Smithsonian or in the
somewhat disorderly atmosphere
of the library's rooms
in the Capital.
These losses could have
occurred at either institution.
The initial Smithsonian request to
the library regarding the return
of the collection was made
during the preparation
of the temporary exhibit for
the Cincinnati fair of 1888.
Five years later, as the institution
assembled another display
for the world's Columbian
exposition to be held in Chicago,
further inquiries were made but
they received little response.
Secretary Langley corresponded
with Spofford in May 1893.
Revising, revisiting the question
of the Marsh prints that remained
at the library, Langley wrote,
"the institution now finds itself
in a position to resume their care
and is considering the
advisability of doing so."
But he did not ask for
their outright return.
He recognized the difficulty of
determining the specific contents
of the collection beyond what
had been returned in 1888.
The lack of registration for the
collection sent to the library,
together with inconsistent formats
of single prints, portfolios,
and bound volumes of engravings,
must have confused the process.
He enclosed a list of the works
delivered to your keeping in 1886,
which is complete so far as is
known, but which I have reason
to suppose did not include
many things actually sent.
While the list specifies the number
and general character of engravings
in each portfolio, it
does not, I regret to say,
appear to correctly specify
the number of portfolios
or specify each separate engraving.
This list, which I have not
located, apparently was based
on Marsh's original sales agreement
with additional details supplied
from Jewett's 1850 report.
But it must have merely reflected
these earlier compilations
and still did not accurately
identify what actually had
been sent.
Langley asked Spofford to
investigate the preparation
of requisite facilities for
examination by a suitable person,
presumably that would be
Koehler, within the next month.
But there is no indication
of any response
or any subsequent examination
by Smithsonian personnel.
So the Marsh collection has
become a contested treasure.
In his 1896 report to the Board of
Regents, Langley discussed the role
of art and the value of
the Marsh collection.
He stated that the original act
creating the Smithsonian had
mentioned art objects before
those of natural history,
yet the scientific side
of the institution had outpaced
its aesthetic activities.
He felt the original intent by
Congress was for the Smithsonian
to be a curator of the national art
and that this function
has never been forgotten,
although often in abeyance.
He asked the Regents to take formal
action to reclaim the engravings,
etchings, and other works of
art dispersed to the Corcoran
and to the Library of Congress.
As he stated, the transfer was
made with the express understanding
that they were there for
deposit only and to be reclaimed
by the regents at any time.
Beyond the immediate
need for exhibition use,
other factors prompted
this renewed interest.
Langley understood the important
role of prints in the culture,
both in terms of their function
as surrogates or reproductions
for those still assumed to be
unobtainable works of painting
and sculpture, and as markers
of cultural authority
for the institution.
There was also the question
of their monetary value,
and he stressed the
increase in their worth
since the initial purchase.
Almost all of the engravings sent
to the Corcoran were
located and returned.
Even upon Langley's official request
however, it still proved difficult
for the Library of Congress
to identify Marsh's prints.
In theory, the Smithsonian deposit
had its own separate dedicated
section within the library, but over
the years those arrangements had
become rather lax as the
library's acquisitions outgrew
available storage.
While working to retrieve
the Marsh collection,
Langley implicitly reaffirmed
the Smithsonian's ownership
of all the deposit material,
which remained a critical resource
for the institution's
research staff.
For the better part of
a decade, correspondence
between Smithsonian secretaries
and the Librarian of Congress fell
into a pattern of repeated requests
by the Smithsonian and a litany
of excuses pleading for
more time from the library.
Spofford was deeply
engaged in planning
and constructing the
library's new building,
and he seems to have
pacified the Smithsonian
by saying they would look for the
missing volumes and engravings
when the collections were
moved from the capital.
However, when the splendid
edifice now known
as the Library's Jefferson
building opened in 1897,
there was a large gallery on
the second floor dedicated
to the display of prints.
Several exhibition cases
in this grand space contained
prints identified as selections
from the Marsh collection.
Far from being unable to identify
which prints had come from Marsh,
it seems the library had
other plans for them.
With the new building
came a new agenda
and a new department
devoted to prints.
Marsh's collection was an important
component of this new endeavor
for the library, which reflected
the considerable interest in prints
in American society at that time.
Neither Spofford nor his
successors were inclined
to return the Marsh collection.
In their view, the collection
was better suited to the Library
of Congress than to
the National Museum.
As the newly appointed Librarian
Herbert Putnam wrote to Langley
in 1899, in a conversation at your
office some weeks ago you mentioned
to me the Marsh collection
of engravings
as having disappeared from view.
I have had an examination made
here and am inclined to believe
that the Marsh collection came to
the library, and that it forms now,
part of the collection of prints.
Some of the engravings
now on exhibit
in the print department
are examples from it.
We do not however, find any record
that is precise as to the contents
of the collection when
transferred to us.
It would be a satisfaction to you,
as to us, to have such a record.
And later in the course of the
classification and arrangement
of the print department
in competent hands,
such a statement could
doubtless be compiled.
So Putnam admits to the library's
possession of the Marsh prints,
but at this point, they
were on public display
and obviously considered part
of the library's collection.
He seemed to be willing to make a
record of them, but said nothing
about restitution to
the Smithsonian.
Most tellingly, Putnam used the word
transfer instead of the word deposit
in reference to the prints, although
other Smithsonian items mentioned
in this same letter were
identified as deposits.
Putnam left no doubt about
the library's position.
And to reinforce it, he sent on loan
a volume with thirty-three pieces
of flags captured by
American ships in 1812
as material deemed more
appropriate for the National Museum.
Putnam's position favored
leaving the prints in the library,
perhaps because he
considered them to be more
like books than museum objects.
Prints were held in many library
collections as well as in museums.
Individual collectors, like Marsh
and others, acquired both books
and prints without much concern
for separation by medium or format.
The practice of extra illustration
was at its height at this time,
and many collectors eagerly
acquired prints which they used
to embellish bound volumes.
Distinctions between prints and
books were not clearly defined,
or consistently observed, as
reflected in their close affinities
over centuries of collecting.
Another factor that
contributed to the dispute
over the collection was the
cultural importance of prints.
What one curator has called
the great bull market imprints,
extended from about 1870 all the way
to the Great Depression,
ending about 1930.
Engravings and etchings continued to
be sought after in the art market,
and their acquisition represented
significant achievements
for institutions as well
as individual collectors.
George W Vanderbilt, in his palatial
North Carolina home, Biltmore,
completed in 1895, displayed
many prints including Dürer's
multi-sheet woodcut, the triumphal
arch, now in the music room.
Institutions vied with each other
to capture the largest collection
from the most important collectors.
They exhibited their prints proudly,
featuring these works almost
like the trophy heads, shot and
mounted by big game hunters.
In this environment, it's no wonder
that these two institutions vied
for this, for this collection.
Soon after the opening
of the Jefferson building
and its print gallery,
library employee Jessie Porter Woode
reported on the division of prints
in the American art annual.
Although not designated a curator,
Woode obviously knew
the collection well.
She was hired in 1897 as an
assistant in the reading room.
As an artist, she may have proved
herself useful to this new division.
The Library of Congress
first began to hire women
with the opening of
the new building.
These appointments were considered
an experiment, and in the opinion
of Librarian John Russell Young,
"open to debate" [laughter].
He felt that manual labor
involved in handling
and organizing library materials,
especially as part of the move
from the capital, was too
difficult for women, for whom gentle
and more useful offices
were more suitable.
Perhaps this gender bias actually
operated to Woode's benefit
by placing her in the
print department
where she seems to
have had an affinity.
The Marsh collection received
prominent mention in her entry
for the art annual, and this
is the page illustrating it.
While acknowledging that
the collection belonged
to the Smithsonian, the article
nonetheless included an illustration
that identified it as
a prominent component
of the library's print exhibit.
Woode mistakenly assumed that
Marsh had assembled the collection
in Europe while serving
as U.S. minister to Italy,
but he wasn't appointed
to that post until 1861.
She also commented, incorrectly,
that many of the most
valuable prints were retained
by the Smithsonian.
She described the collection using
language that, half a century later,
still borrowed from
Jewett's annual report.
But she did offer some new
information about the division
of individual portfolios between
the library and the Smithsonian.
In enumerating the Dürers, she
tallied 100 prints that remained
at the library, including the
engravings Marcantonio copied
after Dürer's woodcut
life of the Virgin,
which the 1850 report had
described as the "famous seventeen"
in reference to the lawsuit
that Dürer supposedly
instigated over this plagiarism.
The Rembrandt portfolio, she
said, was largely picked over
and the better part
kept at the Smithsonian.
Also, the third portfolio
containing 200 engravings
by Claude Lorraine,
Hollar, and Vega.
That assessment does not tally
with the current locations
for these prints, and she did not
mention Marsh's early 16th century
chiaroscuro woodcuts by
Hugo di Carpi and Coriolano
that remain at the library.
Woode's article provides
some specific clues
about which prints were located
in each institution around 1900.
But her notion of their division
and distribution made it sound
like the two institutions had agreed
to some equitable disposition,
even though such a
process is not reflected
in the surviving correspondents.
Her description continued.
The contents of a fourth
portfolio were divided
and the library received a
collection of engraved portraits
by [inaudible], among them, a first
impression of Louis XIV in armor,
8 by [inaudible], and a number
by [inaudible] [foreign
language], and others.
There's also a scrapbook in which
is arranged a beautiful collection
of portraits of the French
school in the 17th century.
The fifth portfolio,
reported to contain examples
of old Italian engravings,
was probably culled
over at the Smithsonian
and the better part kept.
For the library has only a few,
among them, two by Marcantonio
and some representative prints from
the hand of Karachi, Salvatore Rosa,
[inaudible], Volpato
and Rafael Morgan.
Added to this is a small
collection of Dutch, Flemish,
and English prints of the
16th, 17th and 18th centuries.
Woode concluded that the Marsh
collection illustrated the growth
of engraving, and that it
was splendidly supplemented
by the recent acquisition
of the Hubbard collection.
The Gardner Green Hubbard collection
was another bone of contention
between the library
and the Smithsonian.
Hubbard, a founder of the
Bell telephone company,
was a wealthy philanthropist
who also served as president
of the National Geographic Society.
Langley named Hubbard to the
Smithsonian's Board of Regents
in 1895, presumably in
the hope of wooing him
and his renowned collection
of prints.
Assistant Secretary Goode knew
Hubbard well and advised him
about Japanese prints, rare books,
and their shared interest
in genealogy.
After Hubbard died in December 1897,
his widow Gertrude gave the
collection to the Library
of Congress, although she seems
to have negotiated
with both institutions.
She corresponded with Koehler
about some of the prints
and she set certain conditions
that the Smithsonian was either
able or unwilling to meet.
She wanted a named gallery
for a perpetual exhibition
of the collection, complete
with her husband's bust,
and this stipulation
was incompatible
with the National Museum's
exhibition policy.
In accepting the gift for the
library however, the Senate failed
to approve naming the
gallery for an individual.
The practice was considered
unsuitable
and undesirable in
a public building.
Perhaps the Smithsonian
should've tried harder
to acquire Hubbard's collection
if that was the main objection
to the term of the gift.
It's very possible too that Goode's
untimely death in 1896 was a factor
in the Hubbard's decision
to donate to the library,
as his loss certainly
figured in the failure
to restore the Marsh
collection to the Smithsonian.
John Russell Young, who served
as Librarian of Congress
for a brief interlude
between Spofford and Putnam,
wrote eloquently about
Hubbard's prints.
The collection was described as, in
many respects, the most instructive
and valuable in the country,
words that resemble
Jewett's justification
for the Marsh purchase.
Tastes hadn't changed, and
many of the same artists
and prints were represented.
Young's 1898 report on the
library included an appendix
on the Smithsonian that
concerned relations
between the two institutions.
Langley was invited to participate,
and his remarks corresponded
somewhat with spot, a contribution
that Spofford made to the 1896
history of the Smithsonian.
So despite the impasse
over the Marsh collection,
the two institutions remained
in reasonably cordial
professional relation.
In the early years
of the 20th century,
several initiatives propelled the
Smithsonian into the realm of art.
Gifts of painting and sculpture
prompted its designation
as the National Gallery, and Charles
Lang Freer's significant donation
of Asian and American works led to
the creation of the Freer Gallery
of Art as a separate museum
within the institution.
The Smithsonian's official
recognition as the National Gallery
of Art, the name that
was in use until 1937,
when the melon gift created
another National Gallery of Art
at the east end of them all,
resulted from the terms of a bequest
by Harriet Lane Johnston, a niece of
President Buchanan, who stipulated
that her collection of painting
and sculpture be placed
in a National Gallery.
In 1906, the Supreme Court of
the District of Columbia ruled
that the Smithsonian could be
considered within the definition
of a National Gallery based
on the original language
of the enabling legislation.
So Johnston's collection
came to the institution,
soon followed by the William
Evans gift and several others.
Washington newspapers
covered the story as if
to say the Smithsonian was always
intended as a National Gallery,
designed to cherish
art, one headline read,
a prime duty of the
Smithsonian since its founding.
Well, not exactly, as we've seen.
Articles focused on
the new collections,
but also mentioned Marsh
as a historical example.
The early Marsh purchase was
cited as a lucky speculation,
and its location
at the Congressional Library
only a temporary deposit.
Another article, while giving most
attention to the Johnson, Evans,
and Freer gifts, also mentioned
Marsh's valuable etchings
and engravings, noting that they
resided at the Library of Congress,
but expressing the idea that they
would probably soon be transferred
to the new National Gallery.
This information may have been given
to the press by the Smithsonian
in the hope of finally
retrieving the collection
from the library, but
it was not to be.
Langley died in 1906 and subsequent
secretaries made no sustained effort
to reclaim the prints.
In the end, administrative
decisions made
in later decades favored leaving
the entire Smithsonian deposit,
including Marsh's collection,
at the Library of Congress.
What began in the 1840s as an
individual scholar's gathering
for his personal enjoyment
and to share
with his friends became a
public collection available
to national audiences for more
than a century and a half.
As accessible objects with
shared social meaning,
these prints contributed
to the growth
of the Smithsonian in
its formative years.
The story of building this private
collection informed the public
process of institution building.
The Marsh collection
was a critical element
in the Smithsonian's
development of cultural authority
as the United States took its place
as a new nation facing
the old world.
Traditional European works
were considered necessary
for international credibility,
and Marsh's prints came
ready-made to suit that purpose.
The same impulses obtained at the
Library of Congress as it expanded
in a period when prints were highly
valued, leading to their efforts
to retain the collection.
In both institutions, the presence
of the Marsh collection enriched
the nation's cultural heritage.
I'd like to thank my
colleagues here at LC once again,
for their valued cooperation.
I know they are just as pleased
as I am to uncover the [inaudible]
of Marsh's prints and
books that remain here,
which we are still identifying.
Digital imaging options
now allow for collections
to reach a wide audience online.
You can see the entries
that we're posting
on the American history website at
marshcollection.si.edu and other,
other images here at loc.gov.
Their physical locations
become less important as long
as they are well documented.
Together, we're making up for
the decades of lost information.
Thank you.
[applause]
>> We have time for a few questions.
>> Helena E. Wright: Okay, sure.
>> [Inaudible].
>> We have a new batch of
scans on the works, don't we?
>> Helena E. Wright: We do.
>> So we have about twenty
more beautiful scans on the,
in our [inaudible] shortly
based on your research.
I mean, you're really helping us
to reconstruct the collection.
>> Helena E. Wright:
Well, it's been a pleasure
to work with you, I must say.
And if you do want to find
them, the best way is to type
"marsh collection" in quotes in the
prints and photographs search page.
>> Other questions?
>> Helena E. Wright: Linda, hi.
>> Hi Helena.
Thank you so very much,
it was fascinating.
So his focus, Marsh's focus,
was on the copper plate.
So how is it that some
woodcuts, do you have any idea,
was there any indication of why
he did acquire some woodcuts?
>> Helena E. Wright: Well he
was interested in early prints.
He uses, they use the
term engravings
as a rather encyclopedic
description.
He's not restricting
it by medium really.
>> Oh, I see.
>> Helena E. Wright:
He's including woodcut.
He had quite a number of
woodcuts in the collection.
>> Okay.
>> Helena E. Wright: Not just the
wonderful chiaroscuros that you know
so much about, but the Dürer
woodcuts and others, so.
>> So he considered -
>> Helena E. Wright: It was a,
it was a kind of a
generic term at the time.
>> Interesting.
Okay. Thank you.
>> Do you know if he
continued collecting
after he went to Turkey and -
>> Helena E. Wright: Well I, that
was one of my early questions,
and using the Marsh papers
at the University of Vermont,
it's pretty clear that he did not.
Much of my information about the
formation of the collection comes
from the invoices which remain there
so we can track what he acquired,
when he got it, the fact that
he was using mostly booksellers
in the United States, some
of whom wrote abroad for him
or he would use European
catalogs and mark the things off
and tell them what he wanted.
But it was a lot of
shipment and buying a lot
of unseen things that
were sight unseen.
He was going on the basis
of reference material, so.
But no, he didn't, he did not
seem to acquire, primarily I think
because his financial
situation was always, I mean,
he was never a very, very flush.
He took these two diplomatic
assignments as a way of,
he thought it was at
a cheaper way to live.
He got a pretty good stipend and
could live more economically abroad
but his situation here
was not very good.
He lost a lot of money in the panic
of 1837 that didn't really catch
up with him until the 40s,
like several other people.
Actually the other two collectors
I mentioned, Robert Gilmore
and Francis Collay Gray also
lost quite a bit of money
in the 1840s and were pretty shaky.
Gilmore had to sell his collection
and Gray was rescued by a nephew
who helped him with investment
so he was able to retain it
and his collection is now at
Harvard and there's a complete,
a pretty complete collection
of that.
So it's interesting to compare
what these individuals acquired
at roughly the same time
and a rather odd coincidence
that they had essentially
bankruptcy problems
at essentially the same time.
Yes.
>> Where is the Marsh
collection contained
in the Smithsonian
in your department?
>> Helena E. Wright: It's in the, in
the graphic arts department division
of the National Museum
of American History.
As you may know, we were the
Museum of History and Technology
for many years and we were the
descendant of the early division
of graphic arts that was formed
in the ANI building in the 1880s.
So, we have the oldest print
collection in the Smithsonian as a,
it's a legacy collection of that,
and it is not necessarily related
to American history, although
Marsh is an American congressman
and the story of what he
acquired is of interest
to American history even though what
he acquired was not American, so.
And he was a member of
the American Art Union.
He did have some American
prints, but they didn't come to,
with the rest of the collection.
I don't know what happened to them.
>> And his books are also in
the graphic art department
or they're in the library?
>> Helena E. Wright: A few of
his, well, the books that he sold
to the Smithsonian, some
of them were retrieved
with that early batch in the 1880s.
So his, some of his reference books,
and some of the large illustrated,
books that are illustrated
with engravings,
probably three dozen or so.
There are, I'm assuming that the
rest of the books he sold are
in the library's collection,
some probably in rare books,
some in the general
collection perhaps.
But his, he did, he did
continue to collect books.
He couldn't stop himself
from collecting books
and they were, they were cheaper.
The art market was rising rapidly
so that was another reason he
didn't replace the print collection.
But he did continue to acquire
books and those were purchased
from his widow and are in
the library at the University
of Vermont where his papers are.
But they are not on, necessarily on
art subjects, there are a few things
that published later, later in the
19th century on art topics but.
Yes.
>> And he, you say that when the
Smithsonian originally acquired the
Marsh, or purchased the Marsh
collection, it was in portfolios
and albums and a single sheet.
So were the, were the albums
things that he assembled
or did he acquire albums
as a, as an item?
>> Helena E. Wright:
Well, the only one
that remains intact is this early
German album and that has his hand,
I can show you the image of that,
perhaps if I can get back to it.
This is something that our paper
conservator went over with me.
He, okay, he ruled around
each of these prints.
He wrote their batch numbers
just to the bottom left.
I'm not sure if you
can see that in the.
>> Yeah.
>> Helena E. Wright: Or I should,
I should, I should make that.
>> Well there's something
at the bottom right.
>> Helena E. Wright: Yeah.
I should make that the slideshow.
Oops. Well, I'm sorry, I was
trying to hit the current slide.
Anyway, It's manila
paper that he ruled
and wrote the batch numbers on.
So he assembled those.
But as far as the rest
of them, who knows.
Some of them have little
numbers, little pencil numbers
in his handwriting indicating an
order, some of the larger prints.
So that might've been their
order within the portfolio,
but I don't know what the
portfolio itself looked like.
>> Interesting.
>> We can take two more questions
and then we're going
to have a book signing.
Does anybody else want to?
Yes sir.
>> Has there been an effort
past the world's fair and now
that we've made these between
the librarian and the Smithsonian
to maybe gather some of the
select pieces for an exhibition?
>> Helena E. Wright: We
haven't discussed that,
but it's a great idea.
I was going to do an exhibition
around the publication of the book,
but we're doing a lot of
construction and renovation
in the building, in my building
at the American History building,
so there wasn't a space for it.
And I was going to do one that
would go to the University
of Vermont Gallery and
one at Dartmouth where,
where Marsh graduated and
where his portrait is,
and then close at American history.
But the construction schedule
kept getting pushed farther
and farther back and it just,
it just didn't make any
sense in terms of timing, so.
But that's an interesting thought
to put some things together
from both of our collections and.
>> John Cole: We can call that
a future collaborative effort
that could grow out of this book.
Again, I was so impressed when
I read the book with the amount
of research and while so
many subjects are covered,
you really did a wonderful job
in pulling out the highlights
and showing, I know the emphasis
between LC and the Smithsonian,
but that's also an
area for future work.
And we're going to have a
book signing, but Helena,
you did a wonderful job on the
book and in the presentation,
and let's show our
appreciation [applause].
The books are on sale in the back
and she will be signing them.
And I thank you again for pulling
this together and coming here.
>> Helena E. Wright: Do I need
to, I should probably close this.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.